ح
[Silence]
‏oke
‏ja
[Silence]
الله اكبر الله اكبر اشهد ان لا اله الا
الله اشهد ان محمدا رسول الله حي على
الصلاه حي على الفلاح قد قامت الصلاه قد
قامت الصلاه الله اكبر الله اكبر لا اله
الا
الله استقيموا واستووا تراصوا
واعتدلوا
الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضال
امين
لتجدن اشد الناس عداوه للذين امنوا اليهود
والذين
اشركوا
ولتجدن اقربهم موده للذين امنوا الذين
قالوا انا
صارى ذلك بان منهم قسيسين
ورهبانا وانهم لا
يستكبرون واذا سمعوا ما انزل الى الرسول
ترى اعينهم تفيض من الدمع مما عرفوا من
الحق
يقولون يقولون ربنا امن
فاكتبنا مع
الشاهدين وما لنا لا نؤمن بالله وما
جاءنا من الحق ونطمع ان يدخلنا ربنا مع
القوم
الصالحين فاثابهم الله بما قالوا
جنات تجري من تحتها الانهار خالدين فيها
وذلك
جزاء
المحسنين والذين كفروا وكذبوا
باياتنا
اولئك اصحاب
الجحيم يا ايها الذين امنوا لا تحرموا
طيبات ما احل الله
لكم ولا تعتدوا ان الله لا يحب المعت
دين وكلوا مما رزقكم الله حلالا
طيبا واتقوا الله الذي
انتم به
مؤمنون لا يؤاخذكم الله باللغو في ايمانكم
ولكن
يؤاخذكم بما عقدتم
الايمان
فكفارته اطعام عشره مساكين من اوسط ما
تطعمون اهليكم او كسوتهم او تحرير
رقبه فمن لم يجد فصيام ثلاثه
ايام ذلك كفاره ايمانكم اذا حلفتم واحفظوا
ايمانكم كذلك يبين الله لكم ايات
لعلكم
تشكرون يا ايها الذين امنوا
انما الخمر والميسر
والانصاب والازلام رجس من عمل الشيطان
فاجتنبوه
فاجتنبوه لعلكم
تفلحون انما يريد الشيطان اني قع بينكم
العداوه
والبغضاء في الخمر والميسر ويصد
ويصدكم انما يريد الشيطان ان يوقع بينكم
العداوه
والبغضاء في الخمر والميسر ويصدكم عن ذكر
الله وعن
الصلاه فهل انتم
منتهون واطيعوا الله واطيعوا الرسول
واحذروا فان توليتم فاعلموا انما على
رسولنا البلاغ
المبين ليس على الذين امنوا وعملوا
الصالحات جناح فيما طعموا اذا ما اتقوا
وامنوا وعملوا الصالحات
ثم اتقوا وامنوا ثم اتقوا
واحسنوا والله يحب
المحسنين يا ايها الذين امنوا
ليبلونكم الله بشيء من الصيد تناله ايديكم
ورماحكم تناله ايديكم ورماحكم ليعلم الله
من
يخافه
بالغيب فمن اعتدى بعد ذلك فله عذاب
اليم الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده
الله
اكبر الله
[Silence]
اكبر
الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الص صراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين يا ايها الذين امنوا لا تقتلوا الصيد
وانتم حرم ومن قتله منكم
متعمدا
فجزاء مثل ما قتل من النعم يحكم به ذوى
عدل منكم
هديا هديا بالغ الكعبه او
كفاره طعام
مساكين او عدل ذلك صياما ليذوق وبال امره
عفى الله عما سلف ومن عاد فينتقم الله منه
والله عزيز ذو
انتقام احل لكم صيد البحر وطعامه متاعا
لكم
وللسيارات وحرم عليكم صيد البر ما دمتم
حرما واتقوا الله الذي اليه
تحشرون الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
[Silence]
اكبر بسم
الله
[Silence]
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
الحمد
اكبر سمع
الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر
الله
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله
[Silence]
‏ja
ض
صلاه القيام اثابكم الله استقيم
واست
الله
اكبر الله
اكبرلا
بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليه
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين جعل الله الكعبه البيت الحرام قياما
للناس والشهر الحرام والهدي
والقلائد
ذلك لتعلموا ان الله يعلم ما في السماوات
وما في الارض وان الله بكل شيء
عليم اعلموا ان الله شديد العقاب وان الله
غفور
رحيم ما على الرسول الا
البلاغ والله يعلم ما تبدون وما
تكتمون قل يستوي الخبيث والطيب ولو اعجبك
كثره
الخبيث فاتقوا الله يا اولي الالباب لعلكم
تفلحون يا ايها الذين امنوا لا تسالوا عن
اشياء ان تبد لكم تسؤكم وان تسالوا عنها
حين ينزل القران تبدل
عفى الله عنها والله غفور
حليم قد سالها قوم من قبلكم ثم اصبحوا بها
كافرين ما جعل الله من بحيره ولا
سائبه ولا وصيله ولا
حام ولا حام ولكن ان الذين كفروا يفترون
على الله الكذب واكثرهم لا
يعقلون واذا قيل لهم تعالوا الى ما انزل
الله والى الرسول قالوا حسبنا ما وجدنا
عليه
اباءنا اولو كان
اباؤهم لا يعقلون شيئا ولا
يهتدون اولو كان
اباؤهم لا يعلمون شيئا ولا
يهتدون يا ايها الذين امنوا عليكم
انفسكم لا يضركم من ضل اذا
اهتديتم الى الله مرجعكم جميعا
فينبئكم بما كن م
تعملون يا ايها الذين امنوا شهاده بينكم
اذا حضر احدكم الموت حين الوصيه اثنان ذوى
عدل منكم او اخران من
غيركم ان انتم ضربتم في الارض
فاصابتكم مصيبه الموت تحبسونهما من بعد
الصلاه
فيقسمان بالله
لشهادتنا احق من شهادتهما وما اعتدينا انا
اذا لمن
الاثمين فيقسمان بالله ان ارتبتم لا نشتري
به ثمنا ولو كان ذا قربى ولا نكتم شهاده
الله انا اذا لمن الاث
فان فان عثر على انهما استحقا اثما فاخران
يقومان مقامهما من الذين استحق عليهم
الاوليان فيقسمان بالله
لشهادتنا احق من شهادتهما وم اعتدينا انا
اذا لمن
الظالمين ذلك ادنى ان ياتوا بالشهاده على
وجهها او يخافوا ان ترد ايمان بعد
ايمانهم واتقوا الله
واسمعوا والله لا يهدي القوم
الفاسقين يوم يجمع الله الرسل فيقول ماذا
اجبتم قالوا لا علم لنا انك انت علام
الغيوب اذ قال الله يا عيسى ابن مريم اذكر
نعمتي عليك وعلى والدتك اذ ايدتك بروح
القدس اذ ايدتك بروح القدس تكلم الناس في
المهد
وكهلا واذ علمتك الكتاب والحكمه والتوراه
والانجيل واذ تخلق من الطين كهيئه الطير
باذني فتنفخ فيها فتكون طيرا
باذني وتبرئ الاكمه والابرص
باذني واذ تخرج الموتى
باذني واذ كففت بني
اسرائيل عنك اذ جئتهم
بالبينات فقال الذين كفروا منهم ان هذا
الا سحر
مبين واذ اوحيت الى
الحواريين ان امنوا بي وبرسولي قالوا امنا
واشهد باننا
مسلمون اذ قال
الحواريون يا عيسى ابن مريم هل يستطيع رب
ربك ان ينزل علينا
مائده من
السماء قال اتقوا الله ان
كنتم
مؤمنين قالوا نريد ان ناكل منها
وتطمئن قلوبنا ونعلم ان قد
صدقتنا ونعلم ان قد صدقتنا ونكون عليها من
الشاهدين قال عيسى ابن مريم
اللهم ربنا انزل علينا
مائده من
السماء تكون لنا عيدا لاولنا
واخرنا تكون لنا عيدا لاولنا واخرنا
وايه من ك وارزقنا وانت خير
الرازقين قال الله اني منزلها
عليكم فمن يكفر بعد منكم فاني اعذبه عذابا
لا اعذبه احدا من
العالمين الله
اكبر
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين واذ قال الله يا عيسى ابن مريم
اانت قلت للناس اتخذ ذوني وامي الهين من
دون
الله قال سبحانك ما يكون لي ان اقول ما
ليس لي
بحق ان كنت قلته فقد
علمته تعلم ما في نفسي ولا اعلم ما في
نفسك انك انت علام
الغيوب ما قلت لهم الا ما امرتني به ان
اعبدوا الله ربي وربكم
وكنت عليهم شهيدا ما دمت
فيهم فلما توفيتني كنت انت الرقيب عليهم
وانت على كل شيء
شهيد ان تعذبهم فانهم عباد
وان تغفر لهم فانك انت العزيز
الحكيم قال الله هذا يوم ينفع الصادقين
صدقهم لهم
جنات تجري من تحتها الانهار خالدين فيها
ابدا رضي الله عنهم ورضوا عنه ذلك لك
الفوز
العظيم لله ملك السماوات والارض وما
فيهن وهو على كل شيء
قدير بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الحمد لله الذي خلق السماوات
والارض وجعل الظلمات
والنور ثم الذين كفروا ربهم
يعدلون هو الذي خلقكم من طين ثم قضى اجلا
واجل مسما عنده ثم انتم
تمترون وهو الله في السماوات وفي الارض
يعلم سركم وجهركم ويعلم ما
تكسبون وما تاتيهم من ايه
من ايات ربهم الا كانوا عنها
معرضين فقد كذبوا بالحق لما
جاءهم فسوف ياتيهم
انباء ما كانوا به
يستهزئون الم يروا كم اهلكنا من قبلهم من
قرن
مكناهم في الارض ما لم مك لكم وارسلنا
السماء عليهم
مدرارا وجعلنا الانهار تجري من تحتهم
فاهلكناهم
بذنوبهم
وانشان من بعدهم قرنا
اخرين ولو نزلنا عليك كتابا في قرطاس
فلمسوه
بايديهم قال الذين كفروا ان هذا الا سحر
مبين وقالوا لولا انزل عليه ملك ولو
انزلنا ملكا لقضي الامر ثم لا
ينظرون ولو جعلناه ملكا لجعلناه رجلا
وللبسنا
عليهم ما
يلبسون ولقد استهزئ
برسل من قبلك فحاق بالذين سخروا منهم ما
كانوا به
يستهزئون قل سيروا في الارض ثم انظروا كيف
كان عاقبه
المكذبين قل لمن ما في السماوات
والارض قل
لله كتب على نفسه
الرحمه ل ج
معنكم الى يوم القيامه لا ريب
فيه الذين خسروا انفسهم فهم لا
يؤمنون الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه
[Silence]
الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين وله ما سكن في الليل
والنهار وهو السميع
العليم قل غير الله اتخذ وليا فاطر
السماوات
والارض وهو يطعم ولا يطعم قل اني امرت ان
اكون اول من اسلم ولا تكونن من
المشركين قل اني اخاف ان عصيت ربي عذاب
يوم
عظيم من يصرف عنه يومئذ
فقد رحمه وذلك الفوز
المبين وان يمسسك الله بضر فلا كاشف له
الا هو وان يمسسك بخير فهو على كل شيء
قدير وهو القاهر فوق عباده وهو الحكيم
الخبير قل اي شيء
اكبر شهاده قل الله شهيد بيني
وبينكم واوحي الي هذا القران لانذركم به
ومن بلغ اكم لتشهدون ان مع الله الهه اخرى
قل لا اشهد قل انما هو اله واحد وان انني
بريء مما
تشركون الذين
اتيناهم الكتاب
يعرفونه كما يعرفون
ابناءهم الذين خسروا انفسهم فهم لا
يؤمنون ومن اظلم ممن افترى على الله كذبا
او كذب
باياته ان انه لا يفلح
الظالمون ويوم نحشرهم جميعا ثم نقول للذين
اشركوا اين
شركاؤكم الذين كنتم
تزعمون ثم لم تكن فتنتهم الا ان قالوا
والله ربنا ما كنا
مشركين انظر كيف كذبوا على
انفسهم وضل عنهم ما كانوا
يفترون ومنهم من يستمع اليك وجعلنا على
قلوبهم اكنه ان يفقهوه وفي اذانهم
وقرا وان يروا كل ايه لا يؤمنوا
بها حتى فاذا
جاؤوك
يجادلونك يقول الذين كفروا ان هذا الا
اساطير
الاولين وهم ينهون عنه ويون عنه وان
يهلكون الا
انفسهم وما
يشعرون ولو ترى اذ وقفوا على نار قالوا يا
ليتنا نرد ولا نكذب بايات ربنا ونكون من
المؤمنين بل بدى لهم ما كانوا يخفون من
قبل ولو ردوا لعادوا لما نهوا عنه وانهم
لكاذبون وقالوا ان هي الا حياتنا الدنيا
وما نحن
بمبعوثين
ولو ترى اذ وقفوا على ربهم قال اليس هذا
بالحق قالوا بلى
وربنا قال فذوقوا العذاب بما كنتم
تكذبون بما كنتم تكفرون قد خسر الذين
كذبوا
بلقاء الله حتى اذا
جاءتهم ساعه بغته
قالوا قالوا يا حسرتنا على ما فرطنا فيها
وهم يحملون اوزارهم على ظهورهم الا
ساء ما
يزرون الله
اكبر
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين وما الحياه الدنيا الا لعب ولهو ولا
الدار الاخره خير للذين
يتقون افلا تعقلون
قد نعلم انه ليحزنك الذي يقولون فانهم لا
يكذبونك ولكن الظالمين بايات الله
يجحدون ولقد كذبت رسل من قبلك فصبروا على
ما كذبوا واوذوا حتى اتاهم
نصرنا ولا مبدل لكلمات
الله ولقد
جاءك من نبا
المرسلين وان كان كبر عليك
اعراضهم فان استطعت ان تبتغي نفقا في
الارض او سلما في
السماء
فتاتيه
بايه ولو شاء الله لجمعهم على ال هدى فلا
تكونن من
الجاهلين انما يستجيب الذين
يسمعون والموتى يبعثهم الله ثم اليه
يرجعون وقالوا لولا نزل عليه ايه من ربه
قل ان الله قادر على ان ينزل ايه ولكن ان
اكثرهم لا
يعلمون وما من
دابه في الارض ولا
طائر يطي بجناحيه الا امم
امثالكم ما فرطنا في الكتاب من شيء ثم الى
ربهم
يحشرون والذين كذبوا اياتنا صم وبكم في
الظلمات من يشا الله يضلله ومن يشاء يجعله
على صراط
مستقيم قل ارايتكم ان اتاكم عذاب الله او
اتتكم الساعه اغير الله تدعون ان كنتم
صادقين بل اياه تدعون فيكشف ما تدع
اليه ان شاء وتنسون ما
تشركون ولقد ارسلنا الى امم من قبلك
فاخذناهم
بالباساء
والضراء لعلهم
يتضرعون فلولا اذ
جاءهم باسنا
تضرعوا ولكن قست قلوبهم وزين لهم الشيطان
ما كانوا
يعملون فلما نسوا ما ذكروا به فتحنا عليهم
ابواب كل
شيء حتى اذا فرحوا بما اوتوا اخذناهم بغته
اخذناهم بغته فاذا هم مبلسون
فقطع دابر القوم الذين ظلموا والحم الحمد
لله رب
العالمين قل ارايتم ان اخذ الله سمعكم
وابصاركم وختم على قلوبكم من اله غير الله
ياتيكم به انظر كيف نصرف الايات ثم هم
يصدفون قل ارايتكم ان اتاكم عذاب الله
بغته او جهره هل يهلك الا القوم
الظالمون وما نرسل المرسلين الا مبشرين
ومنذرين فمن امن واصلح فلا خوف عليهم ولا
هم
يحزنون والذين كذبوا باياتنا يمسهم العذاب
بما كانوا
يفسقون قل لا اقول لكم عندي
خزا ئ الله ولا اعلم الغيب ولا اقول لكم
اني ملك ان اتبع الا ما يوحى الي قل هل
يستوي الاعمى
والبصير افلا
تتفكرون وانذر به الذين يخافون ان يحشروا
الى ربهم ليس لهم من دونه ولي ولا شفيع ل
لهم
يتقون ولا تطرد الذين يدعون ربهم بالغداه
والعشي يريدون وجهه ما عليك من حسابهم من
شيء وما من حسابك عليهم من شيء فتطردهم
فتكون من
الظالمين وكذلك فتنا بعضهم ببعض ليقولوا
هؤلاء من الله عليهم من
بيننا اليس الله باعلم بالشاكرين
واذا
جاءك الذين يؤمنون
باياتنا فقل سلام عليكم كتب ربكم على نفسه
الرحمه انه من عمل منكم
سوءا بجهاله ثم تاب من بعده واصلح فانه
غفور
رحيم وكذلك نفصل الايات ولتستبين سبيل
المجرمين قل اني نهيت ان اعبد الذين تدعون
من دون الله قل لا اتبع
اهوائكم قد ضللت اذا وما انا من
المهتدين قل اني على بينه من ربي
وكذبتم به ما عندي ما تستعجلون به ان
الحكم الا لله يقص الحق وهو خير
الفاصلين قل لو ان عندي ما تستعجلون به
لقضي الامر بيني
وبينكم والله اعلم
بالظالمين الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله
اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله
[Silence]
خس
بسم
الله
بسم الله الرحم
الرحيم الحمد
لله نحمده ونستعين
ونستغفر ونعوذ بالله من شرور انفسنا ومن
سيئات اعمالنا من يهده الله فلا مضل له
ومن يضلل فلا هادي
له اللهم صل وسلم وبارك ودك محمد وعلى اله
وصحبه اين برحتك ارم
الرحمين رسول الله صلى الله عليه
وسلم they back after where ch been open
and
tak
so
[Silence]
صل
الله
[Silence]
ايمن رضي
عن
الله
‏any
nobody عليه
اللاسلام الله
سبحان الله
سبانت اليت
ال
حسس
[Silence]
علسلام
‏come
[Silence]
‏eas
الله
سبانت عليه
[Silence]
والسلام just you know i want you guys to
imag pain
[Silence]
‏in
‏the amoun of stress and turo that has
to go to person to put grave
[Silence]
deserve
عليه
الصلام الله سبحانه
وتالى
[Silence]
يف عليهه
واللام
egy
house
‏from take egy
and house minister in
egy
ساليه
[Silence]
‏could
‏they impa us truly and change way of
lives and change hearings and and brain
and the whole body we
askes
mann
‏make
سهال
الول الله
take
لا اله الا الله محد رسول الله ربنا اتنا
في الدنيا حسنه وفي الاخره حسنه وقنا عذاب
النار وقنا عذاب القبر وقنا عذاب جهنم
وقنا عذاب فتنه محيا الممات وقنا عذاب
فتنه المسيح الدجال ربنا اغفر لنا
ولوالدينا والمسلمين والمسلمات والمؤمنين
والمؤمنات الاحياء منهم الاموات ربنا تقبل
منا انك انت السميع العليم وتب علينا يا
مولان تواب الرحيم وصلى الله على محمد
وعلى اله وصحبه اجمعين برحمتك ياارحم
الرحمين اللهم امين اللهم امين اللهم
[Silence]
امين استقيموا اعتدلوا استووا سووا
الصف الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين
وعنده مفاتح الغيب لا يعلمها الا هو ويعلم
ما في البر والبحر وما تسقط من ورقه الا
يعلمها ولا حبه في ظلمات الارض ولا رطب
ولا يابس الا في كتاب
مبين وهو الذي
يتوفاكم
بالليل وهو الذي
يتوفاكم بالليل ويعلم ما
جرحتم
بالنهار
ثم يبعثكم فيه ليقضى
اجل ليقضى اجل
مسمى
ثم اليه
مرجعكم وهو الذي
يتوفاكم بالليل ويعلم ما
جرحتم
بالنهار ثم يبعث
فيه ليقضى اجل
مسمى ثم اليه مرجعكم ثم
ينبئكم بما كنتم
تعملون وهو القاهر فوق عباده ويرسل عليكم
حفظه حتى اذا جاء احدكم الموت توفته
رسلنا توفته رسلنا وهم لا
يفرطون ثم ردوا الى الله مولاهم
الحق الا ثم ردوا الى الله مولاهم الحق
الا له الحكم وهو اسرع
الحاسبين قل من
ينجيكم من ظلمات البر والبحر
تدعونه تدعون
تضرعا وخفيه لئن انجانا من هذه
لنكونن من
الشاكرين قل الله
ينجيكم منها ومن كل كرب ثم انتم
تشركون قل هو القادر على ان يبعث عليكم
عذابا من
فوقكم ان يبعث عليكم عذابا من فوقكم او من
تحت
ارجلكم او يلبسكم
شيعا او يلبسكم شيعا ويذيق
بعضكم باس
بعض انظر كيف نصرف الايات لعلهم
يفقهون وكذب به قومك وهو الحق
قل لست
عليكم
بوكيل لكل نبا
مستقر وسوف
تعلمون واذا رايت الذين يخوضون في اياتنا
فاعرض عنهم حتى يخوضوا في حديث
غيره واما
ينسينك الشيطان
واما
ينسينك الشيطان فلا تقعد بعد الذكرى مع
القوم
الظالمين الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده
الله
اكبر الله
[Silence]
اكبر
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين وما على الذين يتقون من حسابهم من
شيء ولكن ذكرى لعلهم
يتقون وذر الذين اتخذوا دينه
لعبا
ولهو وذكر به ان تبسل نفس بما كسبت ليس
لها من دون الله ولي ولا
شفيع وذر الذين اتخذوا دينهم
لعبا
ولهوا وذكر به ان تبسل نفس بما كسبت ليس
لها من دون الله ولي ولا
شفيع و وذكر به ان تبسل نفس بما كسبت ليس
لها من دون الله من ولي ولا
شفيع وذر الذين اتخذوا دينهم لعبا ولهوا
وغر هم الحياه
الدنيا وذكر به ان تبسل نفس بما كسبت ليس
لها من دون الله من ولي ولا
شفيع وان تعدل كل عدل لا يؤخذ منها اولئك
الذين ابسلوا بما
كسبوا لهم شراب من حميم عذاب اليم بما
كانوا
يكفرون قل اندعوا من دون الله ما لا
ينفعنا ولا
يضرنا ونرد على اعقابنا بعد اذ هدانا
الله كالذي استهوته الشياطين في الارض
حيران له اصحاب
يدعونه الى الهدى
اتنا قل ان هدى الله هو
الهدى وا وامرنا لنسلم لرب
العالمين وان اقيموا الصلاه واتقوه وهو
الذي اليه
تحشرون وهو الذي خلق السماوات والارض
بالحق ويوم قول كن
فيكون قوله الحق وله الملك يوم ينفخ في
الصور يوم ينفخ في الصور عالم الغيب
والشهاده عالم الغيب
والشهاده وهو وهو الحكيم
الخبير الله
اكبر
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
[Silence]
اكبر
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله
[Silence]
اكبر الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين واذ قال ابراهيم لابيه ازر را تتخذ
اصناما الهه اني اراك وقومك في ضلال
مبين وكذلك نري ابراهيم ملكوت السماوات
والارض وليكون من
الموقنين فلما جن عليه الليل راى كوكبا
قال هذا ربي فلما اثل قال لا احب
الافلين فلما راى القمر فلما راى القمر
بازغ بازغا قال هذا
ربي فلما افل قال يا قوم لئن لم يهدني ربي
لاكونن من القوم
الضالين قال لئن لم يهدني ربي
الضالين
فلما راى الشمس
بازغه قال هذا ربي هذا
اكبر
فلما افلت قال
اني
بريء مما
تشركون قال يا قوم اني
بريء
مما
تشركون
اني وجهت وجهي للذي فطر السماوات والارض
حنيفا
حنيفا وما انا من
المشركين
وحاجه قومه قال اتحا
جوني في الله وقد
هدان ولا اخاف ما تشركون به الا ان
يشاء ربي
شيئا الا ان يشاء ربي
شيئا وسع ربي كل شيء علما افلا
تتذكرون وكيف فاخاف ما اشركتم ولا تخافون
انكم
اشركتم وكيف اخاف ما اشركتم ولا تخافون
انكم اشركتم بالله ما لم ينزل به عليكم
سلطانا فاي الفريقين احق بالامن ان كنتم
تعلمون
الذين امنوا ولم يلبسوا ايمانهم بظلم
اولئك
اولئك لهم الامن وهم
مهتدون وتلك
حجتنا اتيناها ابراهيم على قومه نرفع
درجات من
نشاء
ان ربك حكيم
عليم ووهبنا له اسحاق ويعقوب كلا
هديناه ونوحا هدينا من قبل ومن
ذريته ومن ذريته داوود وسليمان وايوب
ويوسف وموسى
وهارون وكذلك نجزي المحسنين
وزكريا ويحيى وعيسى والياس كل من
الصالحين واسماعيل واليسع ويونس واسماعيل
واليسع ويونس
ولوطا وكلا فضلنا على
العالمين ومن
ابائهم
وذرياتهم
واخوانهم
واجتبيناهم
وهديناهم الى صراط
مستقيم ذلك هدى الله يهدي به من
يشاء من عباده ولو اشركوا لحبط عنهم ما
كانوا
يعملون اولئك الذين
اتيناهم الكتاب والحكم والنبوه
فان يكفر بها
هؤلاء فان يكفر بها
هؤلاء فقد وكلنا قوم اللي فقد وكلنا بها
قوما ليسوا بها
بكافرين
اولئك الذين هدى الله فبهداهم
اقتده قل لا اسالكم على عليه
اجرا ان هو الا ذكرى
للعالمين الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الض
ضالين
امين وما قدروا الله حق قدره اذ قالوا ما
انزل الله من
شيء وما قدروا الله حق قدره اذ قالوا ما
انزل الله من ش على بشر من شيء
قل من انزل الكتاب الذي جاء به
موسى قل من انزل الكتاب الذي جاء به موسى
هدى ونورا للناس
تجعلونه قل من انزل الكتاب الذي جاء به
موسى نورا وهدى للناس تج تونه
قراطيس تجعلونه قراطيس تبدون وتخف وتخفون
كثيرا
وعلمتم ما لم تعلموا انتم ولا
اباؤكم قل
الله
ثم ذرهم في خوضهم
يلعبون وهذا كتاب ان نزلناه مبارك مصدق
الذي بين يديه ولتنذر امما القرى ومن
حولها والذين يؤمنون بالاخره يؤمنون به
وهم على صلاتهم
يحافظون ومن اظلم ممن افترى على الله كذبا
او قال اوحي الي ولم ي اليه شيء ومن قال
سانزل مثل ما انزل
الله ولو ترى اذ الظالمون في غمرات الموت
والملائك ت باسطوا
ايديهم اخرجوا
انفسكم اليوم تجزون عذاب
الهون اليوم تجزون عذاب الهون بما كنتم
تقولون على الله غير الحق وبما
وكنتم
باياته
تستكبرون وكنتم عن اياته
تستكبرون ولقد جئتمونا فرادا كما خلقناكم
اول مره وتركتم ما خولناكم وراء
ظهوركم وما نرى معكم
شفعاءكم الذين زعمتم انهم فيكم
شركاء لقد تقطع بينكم وضل عنكم ما كنتم
تزعمون ان الله فالق الحب
والنوى يخرج حي من الميت ومخرج الميت من
الحي ذلكم الله فانا
تؤفكون فالق الاصباح واجعل الليل سكنا
والشمس والقمر
حسبانا ذلك تقدير العزيز
العليم وهو الذي جعل لكم
النجوم لتهتدوا بها
وهو الذي جعل لكم النجوم لتهتدوا بها في
ظلمات البر والبحر قد فصلنا الايات لقوم
يعلمون وهو الذي
انشاكم من نفس
واحده
فمستقر
ومستودع قد فصل الايات لقوم
يفقهون وهو الذي انزل من
السماء
ماء فاخرجنا به نبات كل
شيء فاخرجنا به نبات كل شيء فاخرجنا منه
خضرا نخرج به حبا متراكبا
نخرج منه حبا
متراكبا ومن النخل من طلعها
قنوان
دانيه
وجنات من اعناب والزيتون
والرمان مشتبها وغير
متشابه انظروا الى ثمره اذا اث ر وينعه ان
في ذلكم لايات
لقوم
يؤمنون وجعلوا لله
شركاء
الجن
وخلقهم وخرقوا له بنين
وبنات بغير علم سبحانه وتعالى عما
يصفون بديع السماوات والارض
انا يكون له ولد
انا يكون له ولد ولم تكن له
صاحبه وخلق كل
شيء وهو بكل شيء
عليم ذلكم الله ربكم لا اله الا هو خالق
كل
شيء فاعبدوه وهو على كل شيء وكيل لا تدركه
الابصار وهو يدرك الابصار وهو اللطيف
الخبير قد
جاءكم
بصائر من
ربكم فمن ابصر فلنفسه ومن عمي
فعليها وما انا
عليكم
بحفيظ وكذلك نصرف الايات وليقولوا درست
ولنبينه
لقوم
يعلمون اتبع ما اوحي اليك من ربك لا اله
الا هو
لا اله الا هو واعرض عن
المشركين ولو
شاء الله ما
اشركو وما جعلناك عليهم
حفيظا وما جعلناك عليهم
حفيظا وما انت عليهم
بوكيل ولا تس الذين يدعون من دون الله
فيسب الله عدوا بغير
علم كذلك
زينا لكل امه
عملهم ثم الى ربهم
مرجعهم
فينبئهم بما كانوا
يعملون واقسموا بالله جهدا ايمانهم لئن
جاءتهم ايه
ليؤمنن بها قل انما الايات عند
الله وما يشعركم انها اذا
جاءت لا
يؤمنون
ونقلب ونقلب ابصارهم وافئدتهم كما لم
يؤمنوا به اول
مره
ونقلب افئدتهم
وابصارهم كما لم يؤمنوا به اول مره
ونذرهم في
طغيانهم
يعمهون الله
اكبر
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
[Silence]
اكبر
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله
[Silence]
ا
الشفع ان شاء
اللهو سوي
الصف الله اكبر الله اكبر
الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا الضال
الين
امين سبح اسم ربك
الاعلى الذي خلق فسوى والذي قدر
فهدى والذي اخرج المرعى فجعله
غثاء احوى سنقرئك فلا تنسى الا ما شاء
الله
انه يعلم الجهر وما يخفى ونيسرك
لليسرى فذكر
ان نفعت
الذكرى سيذكر من يخشى
ويتجنبها
الاشقى الذي يصلى
النار
الكبرى
ثم لا يموت فيها ولا
يحيا قد افلح من تزكى وذكر اسم ربه
فصلى بل تؤثرون الحياه
الدنيا
والاخره
خير
وابقى ان هذا لفي الصحف الاولى
صحف
ابراهيم
وموسى الله
اكب سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله الله
اكبر الله
[Silence]
اكبر الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين قل يا ايها
الكافرون لا اعبد ما
تعبدون ولا انتم عابدون ما اعبد ولا انا
عابد ما
عبدتم
ولا انتم عابدون ما
اعبد لكم دينكم ولي
دين الله الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
[Silence]
اكبر
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله الله الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب
عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين قل هو الله احد الله الصمد لم يلد
ولم يولد ولم يكن له كفوا
احد الله اكب
الله
سمع الله لمن حمده ربنا ولك الحمد حمدا
كثيرا طيبا مباركا فيه اللهم تم نورك
فهديت فلك الحمد عظم حلمك فعفوت فلك الحمد
بسطت يدك فاعطيت فلك الحمد فلك الحمد يا
ربنا كما تحب
وترضى لك الحمد مل السماء والارض وملء ما
بينهما وملء ما شئت من شيء بعد اللهم اقسم
لنا من خشيتك ما تحول به بيننا وبين
معصيتك ومن طاعتك ما تبلغنا به
جنتك ومن اليقين ما تهون به علينا
مصائب الدنيا ومتعنا اللهم
باسماعنا وابصارنا
وقواتنا ابدا ما
ابقيت واجعله الوارث منا واجعل ثارنا على
من
ظلمنا ولا تجعل مصيبتنا في ديننا ولا تجعل
مصيبتنا في ديننا ولا تجعل مصيبتنا في
ديننا ولا تسلط علينا
بذنوبنا من لا يخافك فينا ولا
يرحمنا برحمتك يا ارحم الراحمين اللهم
تقبل منا
صيامنا
وصلاتنا
وقيامنا وقراننا على الوجه الذي يرضيك
عنا اللهم اعز الاسلام
والمسلمين كلمتي الحق والدين المبين وانصر
اخواننا المستضعفين من المسلمين في كل
مكان اللهم انصرهم في غزه
وفلسطين اللهم اجعلهم في امانك اللهم
ادخلهم في ضمانك اللهم ابن عليهم سور
حمايتك اللهم ادفع عنهم ودافع اللهم ادفع
عنهم ودافع وكن لهم معينا
ونصيرا ربنا تقبل منا انك انت السميع
العليم وتب علينا انك يا ربنا تواب
الرحيم اللهم صل وسلم وبارك على سيدنا
محمد وعلى اله واصحابه
والتابعين سبحان ربك رب العزه عما
يصفون وسلام على المرسلين والحمد لله رب
العالمين الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر الله اك
الله
[Silence]
اكبر
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه الله رح
الله
[Silence]
‏l